[Música]
hoy se conmemora el día de la
eliminación de la violencia contra las
mujeres y las niñas una fecha que sigue
llegando o con cifras preocupantes más
de una de cada tres mujeres sufre de
violencia de género durante su vida en
2021 casi una de cada cinco mujeres
entre 20 y 24 años se casó antes de
cumplir los 18 y menos del 40% de las
mujeres sufren violencia y buscan ellas
buscan algún tipo de ayuda menos del 40%
de la buscan precisamente pensando en
esa cifra vamos a poner sobre la mesa
una violencia que está Lamentablemente
normalizada y se trata de la trata con
las mujeres con fines de explotación
sexual me acompaña nuestro estudio mi
compañera Ángela Gómez que realizó un
reportaje sobre este tema para Francia
24 con el apoyo de la fundación Thompson
Rogers Ángela un gusto tenerla acá en
directo América de France 24 buena
mañana Bueno mañana para usted Raúl
Angela vamos a contextualizar a los
televidentes sobre este grave delito no
en el reportaje que usted realizó Bueno
lo Pero entonces la explotación o la
trata de personas es un delito contra la
humanidad es un crimen en el que se se
trasladan personas se sacan de su
entorno y viven condiciones de
explotación no comercialización de seres
humanos dicho esto hay muchas
modalidades está la servidumbre está el
trabajo forzado está la extracción de
órganos está el tema que nosotros
tratamos que es la explotación sexual y
nos enfocamos en esta última Porque
además es la más común en Colombia para
este reportaje hablamos con Fuentes
académicas con activistas hablamos con
las instituciones cuando nos contestaron
el teléfono y la mayoría de personas que
entrevistamos coincidieron en que las
víctimas de explotación sexual en
Colombia de trata con fines de
explotación sexual pueden ser miles
Además de eso la mayoría mujeres la
mayoría venezolanas y la mayoría jóvenes
que cruzan la frontera de manera ilegal
y que son captadas por grupos criminales
sin embargo pese a esta opinión que es
digamos la radiografía común solamente
se registran en 2021 181 víctimas
justamente Ángela uno de estos fenómenos
que usted destaca en el informe es el
subregistro de estas sobrevivientes no
eh Por qué pasa esto mira porque
Colombia Aunque es un país de origen de
tránsito y además
desde desde donde llegan Víctimas de
trata hace digamos apenas lo mínimo para
cumplir con la legislación en torno a
este tema hay un presupuesto irrisorio
que no llega a todas las regiones del
país los funcionarios que trabajan en el
tema se ganan apenas unos sueldos
mínimos en unas condiciones muy
precarias y son rotados constantemente
Porque además sus cargos son utilizados
para pagar favores políticos sobre todo
en las zonas más periféricas del país
mire en Colombia hay más de mil
municipios y es imposible saber cuántos
de esos municipios tienen comités de
lucha antitrata Pese a que por ley
debería estar cobijado todo el
territorio nacional con este tema y otro
caso del su registro Raúl es que no se
conoce el delito entonces no es
debidamente tipificado muchísimas veces
quedan registrados como violencia o como
Pro forzada
porque las autoridades judiciales
tampoco entienden el delito al final las
víctimas prefieren pedir ayuda en ongs
que tienen la expertise pero que tampoco
tienen presupuesto antes de ver este
reportaje Angela y rápidamente Qué hace
el país por las víctimas y no en todas
las realidades por duras que sean
siempre hay algo bueno que destacar
usted lo pone en su reportaje claro mire
en el país si se hacen cosas pero los
esfuerzos Como le decía son muy mínimos
y hay algo muy bello que yo me encontré
y es mujeres mujeres trabajando a lo
largo del país desde la
institucionalidad o desde las ongs para
salvar a más mujeres y pues tienen todas
algo en común falta de presupuesto mucha
energía todo el expertise pero nada de
apoyo y nada de conocimiento del delito
así que bueno lo que le puedo decir Raúl
es que hicimos la tarea de poner estas
voces en el reportaje y pues se le diría
que sean ellas mismas las que nos